also from our eight news now
investigators 17-year-old Keyshawn
Robinson sentenced to 12 and a half
years to life in prison today for
shooting and killing his neighbor and
injuring a two-year-old Last Summer the
victim's family was present in court
today and did not hold back
being a father to my brothers and I and
a grandfather to my kids met him
when he brought to be someone I could
always count on for support we would
attend my brother's football games as a
family together all of his football
games he helped my brothers with their
first jobs learning to drive and
spending quality time together
Robinson is 17 but he may not be
eligible for parole at the earliest
until 2035.